ah on va parler d'île de la tentation ça
y est c'est le grand retour de l'île de
la tentation et on peut le dire
aujourd'hui c'est Delphine qui va
présenter l'île de la tentation vous
partez quand alors dans une semaine non
alors vous êtes contente ou pas je suis
très contente on va partir au Mexique
non pas mal ou alors les Mexicains très
sympa non sans rigoler j'en connais un
Pepito non mais c'est vrai c'est un
super un super mec non mais Melin ouais
non de
Melin Pépito de Melin
oui oui Pépito de Melin non mais
Delphine le c'est le grand retour de
l'île la tentation donc c'est une
émission culte je suis très fire de la
présenter et ça va cartonner et c'est en
deuxième partie de soirée he je crois
euh si si je peux vous le dire ah bon ça
a changé c'était en prime ah non non
c'est en prime c'est vrai sur W en prime
sur W ou mais ils aurait mieux fait de
le mettre en deuxième partie de soirée
prime sur M6 c'est la seule c'est le
seul problème qu' qu' on en tout cas ce
sera en prime sur W9 et ce sera une
expérience incroyable pour des couples
qui se questionnent voilà quand on est
en couple quand on a fait face à du
mensonge à un manque de confiance
peut-être qu' on se pose des
questionsou c'est bon coupl c'est les
couples qui vont pour tester leur amour
c'est surout c'est surtout une meuf ou
un mec un mec une meuf qui se dit je
suis avec un charau elle dit je vais
aller le tester sur une île arrête un
peu non mais oui effectivement c'est
quand il y a des problèmes de confiance
donc ensuite voilà on fait cette
expérience là et comme ça très très vite
on sait si on peut continuer avec cette
personne ou pas souvent les couples ne
continuent pas ensemble effectivement
parce que la tentation est plus for je
vais te dire j'ai jamais vu al tu vas
devoir poser la question donc là il va
avir cette je là je vais devoir faire ça
parce que quand tu arrives il y a le feu
là la fin là donc ils arrivent il y a ta
meuf ou ton mec il a passé une semaine
donc sur l'île et donc à chaque fois et
donc là et donc là il y a a l'iPad et
donc là la meuf est donc là la meuf voit
son
mec
Brit viens
kimbery et là là il VO là non mais c'est
bon c'est bon merci on a tout compris
voilà donc là on voit le mec rentrer
dans la chambre avec Kimberley et là il
y a cette fameuse
phraseavezvous
Laura qu'avez-vous vu qu'avez-vous
entendu génial bah je viens de voir don
mon mec bah caliif Fourchon en train de
de forniquer Britney voilà non mais ça
va être incroyable ça oui ça va être ça
ça va partir en cacahuète je vous dis
c'est sûr alors il y a Séverine qui est
avec nous ce soir elle a participer à la
9e saison de lî de la tentation en 2019
elle était à l'époque en couple avec un
certain Julien on va revenir sur les
moments cultes de lî de la tentation là
là j'ai des j'ai des j'ai des j'ai des
bon bail regardez Delphine en plus ça va
vous inspirer ça va ça va être fort ça
va être
fort je m'appelle Marie j'ai 41 ans je
suis médium et je vis au moond moi c'est
Julien 27 ans j'étais animateur en club
de vacances j'étais parce que justement
j'ai quitté le travail que j'avais pour
venir te rejoindre aujourd'hui je suis
quand même avec lui parce que je me suis
pas mis des barrièr en disant non je
m'arrête là parce qu'il est il a 14 ans
déclare avec moi inspecteur de la valise
cette aventure c'est un grand test parce
que ça nous permettra de savoir si on
peut justement se faire confiance l'un
en l'autre et c'est une bonne preuve
aussi de savoir si on peut envisager par
la suite une relation sérieuse on se met
vraiment en danger on est conscient de
ça le risque zéro n'existe pas j'espère
qu'on va résisteré tous les deux
j'espère mais on sait pas ce qui peut
arriver c'est parti ouais
allez et oui merci Séverine d'être avec
nous c'était une belle expérience il do
la tentation ça reviens bonsoir à
pourquoi vous aviez fait l'île de la
tentation je comprends pas arrêtez moi
la vérité je suis en couple euh jamais
l'île de la tentation mais je vais te
dire l'Î de la tentation tu es sûr et
certain que ton cum va aller tremper son
biscuit
ailleurs non ça dépend mais arrêtez
arrêtez tu btoi regarde c'est ce qui t
arrivé il t'as trompé la viol la
violence
unvit on va dire on va dire que c'est je
vais te remontrer la
vidéo tu veux que je dorme avec toi
c'est ça mais dis pas ça comme si tuas
envie de dormir ce soir non je te
demande tu veux que je dorme avec toi
c'est rien parce que quand je dors je
plus rien donc [__] mais réponds à ma
question tu m'as dit rejoins-moi tu veux
que je dorme avec toi parce que tu m'as
demandé où je dormais tu veux que je
dorme avec toi c'est ça
vas-y ch ok
oui c'est pas toi ça ah non non non
c'est pas moi mais c'est un côté positif
moi on perd pas de temps c'est un
accélérateur de rupture l'Î de la
transais ah ouais c'est vrai bah ça je
te confirme ouais mais vous aviez des
doutes en fait tous les couples qui
Intex ce programme en général ont une
faille dans leur couple donc ils vont
tester donc l'avantage c'est qu'on
attend pas 3 ans de toute façon dans la
vraie vie j'ai envie de vous dire on est
souvent la dernière à le savoir et tout
le monde le sait donc il faut mieux
assumer et être coocu devant toute la
France que les gens qui F ça est-ce qu'
ça pour faire de la télé ou parce que
vraiment il c'est ça c'est ça le truc
Delphine c'est ça le problème al alors
j'ai vu tous les couples et j'ai vu tous
les tentateurs effectivement peut-être
que les tentateurs viennent pour faire
de la télé en tout cas les couples
viennent vraiment pour trouver une vraie
réponse et la vie est longue et en même
temps la vie est courte alors si si on
s'embête à rester pendant des années
avec quelqu'un qui nous trompe ça sert à
rien donc autant aller dans cette
émission là je d' VO Fatou et G là-bas
ça pte en 2
heionexque je voisavez-vous vu j'ai
vu
mais c'est pas Fatou c'est pas ma
France mais c'est magnifique tuagine non
mais c'est trop risqué alors on a votre
réaction quand il vous a quand vous avez
appris que vous étiez trompé donc
regardez
sypa fais
[Musique]
com qu'est-ce que tu as vu dans ces
images c'est j dans chambre avec la
fille qu'il l' embrassé et ben il cache
la caméra donc on imagine la suite ça
n'a pas l'air de te faire vraiment
grand-chose d'avoir vu ces
images en fait ben c'est la suite
logique donc je me'y suis préparée un
peu des images douloureuses mais après
mes émotions je préfère les les vivre
seul en fait parce que je j'ai ma
dignité et et ma fierté
voilà
euh les gars je vais te dire franchement
elle réagit avec dignité ben je réagis
avec dignité je suis déjà cocu devant
toute la France alors vérité tu pas
steak total ah non pas arrête là je te
vois là arrête Fran non non nous étions
un vrai cou alors c'est amusant parce
que je regardais je regardais les photos
il y a pas longtemps on était à New York
juste avant de partir à l'Î de la
tentation et je me disais je vais
peut-être un jour les poster parce que
tout le monde nous pose la question
est-ce que vous étiez un vrai couple non
non on était un vrai couple vraiment
alors un couple qui battait déjà de
l'aile oui ça c'est vrai mais un vrai
couple ça faisait combien de temps que
vous étiez ensemble ça faisait pas très
longtemps ça fait 7 mois je crois non
c'est intéressant et moi ce qui
m'intéresse pardon ça faait pas on
éétait pas un couple de longue date ça
devait faire 8 mois ù on s'était connu
quelqu et ensuite après le retour de l'Î
la tentation parce que c'est ça en fait
on se dit comment est-ce qu'on va
revenir de ça comment ça s pass retour
de l'Î de la tentation rentre en avion
disons à 41 ans on n pas le même recul
que une fille de 20 ans alors les jeunes
filles de 20 ans 25 ans elles étaient
tout pleur alors même si elles avaient
rencontré quelqu'un c'était dur hein
c'était un déchirement entre les couples
enfin c'est un vrai bazar mais à 41 ans
bon on on arrête de souffrir quand on a
déjà eu des ruptures donc plut bien j'ai
env on l'adore elle était venue nous
voir surtout que faut faut faut prendre
le côté positif de la
chose intéressant c'est qu'aujourd'hui
je suis heureuse rement vous avez
rencontré quelqu'un aujourd'hui je suis
avecel c'est le mec kiffe Daniel si vous
pouviez n pas en parler ah ouais c'est
bon pas là pour ça non mais c'est bon
les chéris alors on va voir la la le le
l'émission elle a beaucoup beaucoup
évolué he 2002 on vous a retrouvé le
générique de 2002 je peux vous dire le
générique de 2002 c'est limite un film
noport ouais ouais ouais ah c'est
spectacle
envoyez
[Musique]
hein
c'est au cours au
cours c'est trop dur ce truc c'est c'est
Besin de me
[Musique]
tuer ouais plus ça aujourd'hui alors je
vais vous montrer je vais vous montrer
le générique
20199 vous allez voir et ben ça rien à
voir parce qu'aujourd'hui on va mettre
papa dans maman comme ça sans c'est
dommage
en AM quoi regardez bienvenue sur l'île
de la tentation les couples qui ont
postulé ont vraiment été très nombreux
nous en avons sélectionné uniquement C
CIN couples motivés et déterminés à
mettre leur histoire d'amour à
l'épreuve mais explorer le sentiment
amoureux nécessite parfois de se mettre
en danger ça c'est pas la que je connais
ça m'agace il parle d'alchimie est
complètement
malade ils sont venus ici car ils se
posent des questions sur leur amour vous
êtes venus ici sur de la tentation pour
trouver des réponses à nos questions
est-ce que vous désirez repartir
ensemble ou séparément en repartant ils
sauront bienvenue dans l'île de la
[Musique]
tentation rien à voir rien à voirir
s'ils veulent que ça marche il faut
refaire comme avant sur TF1 il faut que
il y ait de la vraie tromperie la
tromperie c'est un art c'est pas juste
c'est pas non mais c'est pas
juste un connardoi c'est con on peut
plus faire ça unintérêt sinon on a envie
que que ça se galoche vraiment qu'il a
des vraies histoires que ce soit
vraiment chaud sinon aucun intér
question du coup est-ce qu'il aurait pas
fallu le faire sur une plateformme dans
C CASL ouais mais quand tu vois les deux
génériques quand même tuas générique de
2002 où tu bouges pas de ton canapé et
l'autre c'est un reportage en 201 avec
la voix enfin on peut demander quand
même ça c'est vraiment galoché on est
d'accord tout ça en fait les images
trashes vous les avez pas vu mais
effectivement c'était très
trashous parce que les gens se doutaient
que ça allait être un peu plus doux que
l'anenne c'est ça et donc il y en a qui
all directement au
butou pour pas être vu en fait cam
pardon alors ça va être dou ou dur donc
il y aura effectivement tous les
ingrédients de l'île la tentation mais
on va essayer un tout petit peu de de
d'enrober certaines choses pour
préserver quand même les gens parce que
il y aura de la trahison il y aura aussi
beaucoup de pleur donc on va essayer de
faire pour que ce soit ce soit
effectivement une expérience de vie pour
les gens et c'est quel style ton casting
c'est plutôt téléréalité un peu avec des
stéréotypes bimbo un peu genre 2002 ou
c'est un peu plus
a de tout il il y a de tout dans les
couples il y a de tout et dans les dans
les tentateurs et les tentatrices il y a
de tout le casting est fini des
[Rires]
tentatrices alors dans l'Î de la
tentation on a vu beaucoup de scènes
hutes mais on a également vu beaucoup
d'embrouill on rappelle on se rappelle
vous rappelez de Diana
BR à quel point qu'un soir brondon
brondon il il a pété un peu trope ah ou
oui sous le choc des images brondon
enfreint toutes les règles de l'émission
et s'échappe pour rejoindre palmeto le
site des femmes hors de lui brondon
s'est armé d'un bâton et devient
totalement
incontrôlable expérience j'attends ma
femme armé d'un bateau devent
complèementôable l'Î elle s'appelait
quand même
palmo l'autre céit
figolu
alors dans cette émission les candidats
n'avaient pas froid aux yeux je vais
vous montrer cet extrait assez ouf o une
candidate avoue à son mec qu'elle couche
avec son ex depuis le début de leur
relation génial incroyable un faible je
suis un faible ouais je suis un faible
beau qu tu par je peux t'applaudir ou
pas B vas-y lâche-toi ça te fait plaisir
bon on peut je pe j'ai une toute
dernière chose à lui à lui avoué et je
tenais à te dire que en fait depuis le
début que je sors avec toi continuer mon
ex avir har et avoir des relations avec
[Musique]
lui demand pourquoi ils sontemble ils on
pas ils ont l'air de pas du tout
pourquoi parce que il était pas au
courant tout simplement puisque dans ces
cas-là comme vous l'avez bien expliqué
la dernière personne au courant c'est
soi-même c'est souvent soi-même ouais
oui c'est ça qu'on veut c'est des Bell
on l'a dit cette émission c'est très
dangereux pour les couples et ça a brisé
pas mal de cœur certains candidats
étaient en pleur en voyant leur couple
exploser ission et on les comprend
regarde oh là là c'est pas possible
c'est la femme de ma vie qu c'est trop
beau tu vois ce qu'elle t'a
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dit extraordinaire est tombé le pauvre
mais c'estou on rappelle le principe de
l'émission coupl non mari sans enfant
doivent tester leur amour face à la
tentation de 22 22 hommes et femmes donc
11 hommes et 11 femmes sont tentés
pendant 12 jours vous ça peut être 12
[Rires]
minutes
minut jours mais Vuon est tout le temps
tout le temps collé ça démultipe onim
est coupé du monde on est vraiment
ensemble on a pas de téléphone donc on
est coup pas de téléphone mais bon on a
quand même c'est chaud quand même ah
c'est chaud cha ça cré des liens CR conf
euh ben merci en tout cas ça va revenir
sur W9 très vite avec Delphine on vous
regarderaine sera en deième partie de
soirée merci d'avoirté avecouve dans un
instant à tout suite